And you know. I rushed him to come in. That's when I called him you know just yet there.
Yes I'm sorry that was just a big business that I couldn't see Roger Clinton.
You've got don't mention this team guy is breaking into the house nice look down here.
The night before it will let alone to tend to his land sweet
and the condition on the inside something he did look at was you know it's one of those moments of the things it was
it's something to see growing snaking at the deck when you got in the back door
and I think that Indiana for the caves is really desperate which means someone that's a thing that never had to counter
whenever it's been broken into before it's been obvious that it's like a ladder can zoom in this town.
It just puts the next day in the water that it.
Somebody has been there because your base isn't taken Mackay away in it.
They've been given the OK to lock up and taking it away in the vehicle
and thinking I'll come back there in three months to do that you know it's the Internet so we we we were well one of
the Stop beginning to run. Where do you think was the first.
Where do we start well as I don't to go to the tick or are there also
when you move you into a studio give out to the drag shows or bottle bottles
and so well in nine hundred sixty two late late go study Kings Cross.
I understand it was called the Ranch flush it became the jewel box
and that was the first drag show that commercially Kaon when I was there. Previous to that I understand this.
Stork Club is like sixty in the store that was right at our new reading when I was twelve
or thirteen in truth they blew it up now that was Jimmy fish been Johnny fish been the story right and wrong.
Yes at Broughton least Broughton's I am with that bridge there possibly like his comedies bridge
and there was a I understand it.
Jim and woman or an Austrian woman who ran the store club then engine efficiency to how old it was was that young
and Rose Jackson was in that show so she would be about to tell you whether that's about.
I think Rice Jackson came in late had its day that was
when that was the key we boys he's known Joan hump stuff it all so full.
He got the first directions in the store clerk.
Well the first drag show as such as I understand it and this is only from what stories are doing
but the key ways off to the war you with that drag thing they came and did I see at the Capitol Theater
or on the edges of whatever it's called in those days. I'm not sure whether I soared. Or no.
You know how you get hazy of Mother Night of taking me to see if I can remain in the John Hunt on point B.
and Doing the know kind of thing so are doing but it's doing one of those half minute things on the balcony scene.
But even then they're working doing the tuning in
and a New Zealander was in it then cold enough fluffy Friedman that it was sort of one is types of names pussy
something or another and in those days.
I obviously have you know I was twelve or thirteen something of that and I wasn't done nothing
but I understand that they came and from that John Hunter got established they did it well.
I think they did it and they the national tour or an East Coast tour and from that they landed back in Sydney
and I think from that made still club. I can over the years. Yes.
Yeah that's with us now in dry where the other person who might be able to help you with that is of interest.
I mean I think you might do lighting for the opera house and he would John. George.
Jeff George John George with me when I can't go and they need in on the door
and I think he used to do the lots for the Kiwis but you know those people you listen to them.
You don't quite know where they do they do but I think he not have done that and he's jumped George
and the last time I heard of him he was down there for how something exotic unchallengable So we got some.
No go after the stone plus the club. Well I don't remember any like the still club.
The only reason it got to They'd still club was it was a great scandal.
If the page of the trees wrong and then just as women.
And it out got known and have became a scandal was Madame's to cook food
and the patrons nearly died of was just like big boys new pieces and it would be like fifty's I nearly died of them
and that sort of how he
and then you know how those things in that you know up until then I guess it had been in the news.
It's a long way out there. You know years especially in the. Just as well.
I do know the people who know it's a long way there.
I don't think it was it a fantastic six stand testing to be successful then identity mislike grow days with over six
o'clock wasn't just towards existence rather than to the poking and losses in the stores.
I mean in the in those days to a new restaurant one had a license was not being made for him. Yeah that was good.
Yeah he's going to do or you're in the right.
You know stuff stuff and in NOT hundred sixty two you get your books sort of motivation in your endeavor wary
or not about it in the neck then you're sixty one and it then went through like to send the January February
and by then it was becoming fairly popular but it was sort of rough.
I didn't bring a couple of years just say listen think it's like that and a friend of mine
and Barry Dad I did you know if you can be a bit of me
and I think like cool John was decided that it was really good to open a can nine and to open it in the sun.
These are only tablets that I asked to open it on the side of the prison like that was being built at the time in a
suit with a locked right now.
I fact asked my advice
and I said at the time that I thought that if that it was going to be a guy that was too close to King's Cross
and I should go out of it when I manage to fund these things because that what did it used to be before you.
It was originally built to sell on and then it had been turned into a a night club run by straight.
Roger He now runs for T.V.
There and he tried to do a thing called where you came to dinner and there was no been playing
and just people from the tables got up to do that if I lived you like to do something else.
Of course you know like he was a single act
and within his acting try to get people out to do things so well that's window me. J.J.
and John would go to the lake or the purple I guess Don't miss that stone his name for it.
They called it the lawn because he'd taken that from the San Francisco.
There's enough of attendances going to hear the saying so it was it was young going all week right from the start of
the weekend. No it was only open it. I've been all week Tuesday.
Every Sunday because it's been around growth that I could stay in on a Sunday the Tuesday Wednesday Thursday with your
the miserable.
I did the fish everything I was a comedian fish carries in the fish grows checksums in the fish carry something
or another is in the fish a great skating is in the fish and do Rivers and fish and we get to fish
and I think we used to do two shows
and sign openings sang closings big different middles of what if it was fish being produced.
And somehow got involved in that I was working at the time and didn't get involved much because I was a comedian.
So I did not and would like I said I'm going to do this and I going to do it like these next
and then the next second show they're talking about doing that I did the second show with them
but by then I wasn't doing she's done wings day. I don't agree to do this day Friday.
Now don't you going to do Friday citizen to that have another comedian doing it was gone because I got to be like I was
working as it does in the loft and gun to take two and it was just to go there
and there was fair amount of drama in the sense that they got a few square people in
and they had to collect the money for the second show squeeze with if they didn't have bounces
and they would put the show on because the screws didn't pay the money
and I used to get frantic people because we supposed to go on the toilet.
Sometimes you go into one which you can get up to and I had to go to work in the seventy one. If I'm standing.
So I cut it down to one appearing Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Sunday had always being a big No I think totally
involved around the fact that you're being run girl and it cost them nothing like a custom two bucks
or whatever it was to come in and they just gathered up the crowd from the party the night before
and kind of you know as they would. There was no place to sit and go on a Sunday. Only it was never restored.
No eventually got to the stage where they had to sit sandwiches
and things like that in the kitchen because it was never a risk of the eye to have become a restaurant I just have to
make one phone call the other time because a restaurant once when getting older. It wanted to come out more to get.
Yeah and the black C.D.'s are paid in the seven years just here in the States. Joining us now to see you. I'm six.
Do you remember a place called the any For us it was you know the cinema halfway along that mine right down this road
in the cross which is notable as a pinball machine so yes I do remember that
and it's in between after the Purple Onion opened Cuban would learn you know I would have city No sixty two years
because ladles opened in November sixty two and that's not its present song. Yeah yeah.
What happened as far as my personal stuff was considered I did the first show with the maybe the purple
and you know tonight it is.
And the show would run for two months then I did the second show which would have run for another six weeks
and they're into the show and I said I couldn't do it because I was studying and I was working very hard
and they would pay me what I wanted
and I was a big I was a bit sick of it in the sense that there was no organization like it was just a mess still was
there and then they'd sell that to rise.
Jackson who became partner in it
and Jimmy Fishman was directing that really putting sticking his nose in the business side
and really wanting to get in on the business.
With no wanted to get in on some sort of talent that he thought he had you know like and.
If you just got too boring for me even in those days the girls dressed up in that dressing.
And I just don't miss a part
and being the comedian I could really rock five minutes before it went on to get just to go on
and I never ever got involved like the girls Joey stories now.
I never got involved in like some of them were leaving there the time and the trade was there.
I just never was involved in any of that I don't know what the personal things were at that time I left there
and I'd left there and I got wood back that Sammy Lee wanted me to even in his show.
That's how I sort of get that together and I said No I didn't want to do you like this.
And by then he got lost her
and he got in the girls from across you know they're pretty good lookers because I've always felt that the Purple was
the training ground. You know how like they say young film stuff.
Like they said Julie Andrews is really fantastic as a film star because she had to let training they loved English
skills to come over
and make it good in Hollywood because they were trained in whatever they did they went just pretty faces.
Well that's what happened with the purple and in the purple and used to get those kids on a Sunday afternoon
and help and then the big plan on there was like girls but he finally persuaded me to work fifteen.
I would get a tick and I finished ticket nine and I'd be up there by nine thirty. Not that I'd be time for the fish.
And then I would do the late show ID deficient the second show and then I would come home
and that went on for about eight weeks and it was desperately down bodies in the room it was really just nobody can.
Yes it was very struggling and semi's to tears here
and say Yes I've paid he somehow thought he was going to get the Queen's Yes I think fifteen bucks for the seats just
as perfect as I'm done enough. I'm going to what's the matter.
I've got these fantastic show look at these boys did all this there was an incident up at Les Girls where they thought
four of them are there for some reason or another.
I didn't even know what all that was about but there was an incident in the dressing room where rage being kind out
and just screamed at the people he was firing and screen and said You fuckin poofters are all the same of course
and I just dream myself up and said I just have to be one of those who does and I will not be back to myself up
and I never went back there because it was just one of those you know they were square we were camping there
and I wasn't prepared at that stage to work under those conditions. So I left around about December.
Maybe round about December.
Then they had about January first to second send me through to whatever it was they did they didn't mean something on
television
and they'd be thirty teams going to skating Not that I had color on as the boy getting made up to be the beautiful
woman and of being straights the Bankstown of the group because it is just from then on never looked back
and then it just shot forward then from then on after that they just took cues out there
and then it became the glamorous city none of that like it really did for those four years that it ran into five knees.
It was the talk show
and like everybody would like if there was a visiting celebrity they were there for a late night drink
or they have even those people are upstaged is that was a venture that wasn't there to begin with living with that kind
of data and the drink went to well but it was who was there.
Yes it was it then became the trading place for the door and that's wrong.
It's clear that if you come in here for a bit of a look around a week and you're out in December.
Then that we January February
and being Scorpio I think I've been my own club in more London is going all the time through here. Oh.
Jimmy Fishman Did he is the in a round about October because he couldn't get what he wanted from don't know what if it
happened there. I don't know.
He pulled all of the kids out of the onion
and put them in a show called pay bills at the St James stage race put the Legion can make a fugitive down to me on
snoozing surviving which I did it was not a theist and then he packed them down to the peninsula playhouse down.
Avallone and moved in there
and all he succeeded in doing was a needy destroying them years because he pulled the entire cost of not one stand
but fortunately Domi rise Jackson was a prime mover in that because she was friends of Jimmy
and she wanted to get Domi I think.
Fortunately don't we put another show together
and that's way you got Queensland Robin tale coming like that with the second generation going good sort of Robin bow
tail twice a time not that she's you know to try
and people like that came into that second show that Britain Williams and into that second show push there
and in fact to that that show they John hunted it from the original Kiwis he produced and directed it
and it was called How the West was one of the line and he had a beautiful voice
and it used to weigh in with how the West was well that of the boss and Joel was a beat up
and so he said I think you're with the Stars and no show is going to be glamorous because the people.
The queens have gotten used to the Stuff like there could be quite to be like loved to real cool shoes you know what if
she was already a scene good strides
but didn't keep Oh yes trendy thing again she had no luck to carry pushy was young in their graves Christian fuckin
country what is the law
and that the show barely scraped through the door me managed to scrape the onion through because there was nowhere else
to go betweens were there NEVER else to go straight through until eventually of course the fish been stabbed in the
back turned on him and the people started to come back to the cost to drink after only because it just never would.
And eventually it ended up.
I guess we rest Jackson came back quick Harry came back with a cavern came back
and was then just reaching shit your shoes the speaker in your reach and Karen came back seven then Chile.
They all kind back to the onion so it got a new lease of life.
I would have thought in about the December January February of January February of sixty three in February sixty three.
I opened Katie's got to live in Moore and had a long struggle there for about three months
and suddenly the same people who had been coming out to the line in food two years on a Sunday who lived at
paediatrician discovered my show on a Sunday
and suddenly instead of booking the twenty at the end they booked the twenty at me
and of course there's not many people they said they considered fighting to seats
and all that they got the treatment and naturally shows good. Well it really had three in the center of some and none.
And myself and no no because he does something I think he's flown
and shifted to something there is it's really it's in and that was the Stosh and then after that it just build up
and eventually Candy's got to be true which only quite small.
It took a hundred people to have to be crushed in and we became very popular
but what we didn't take was we took the cream off the money
and it in being through such Duraid full financial straits they had to pay.
I think with the snow coming in there were people living and the other still living in the flights of stairs
and they took out objections and they used to pull water through the ceiling.
We used to have to work with the religious and
and then I had to finally pay them five dollars to get there which they paid in of course once you start home.
It's like poor bloody Judy Garland isn't it the less that Texas you can get out of there.
The public should think I'll make a million dollars on this but they would take it in dollars to current taxes
and you know
and they never quite got out of that domain was hopeless with money as with money they didn't have much have to wait
for a while he was pretty good with money but it gets on the vocal for six months.
None of this will be quoted and just you know.
No I don't want these I'm telling you now still to this is a question mark over just yesterday.
I'm just trying to get you into gear is to have all that happen
and then we got then my club became very very popular and the onion went down because of the
and I didn't much like being in it anymore.
You know it was all around that it was really town
and I really wanted to be back at the onion because to me that was the camp.
Although I was getting canned out there sort of a long way to come in around the open Friday Saturday sound before the.
Says it. So why did the end about two hundred.
I think on those nights where they pushed him back in the north and so I made I did choose to do me
and we became I closed the garden day and took my cost over to The Onion
and I don't know whether that was in the June of sixty three
or whether I had gone for nothing at all in more if I had gone for another year doing more it would have been in the
gene sixty four and I think I don't think I was successful if I had been in February.
I don't think I was that successful by Gene.
I think to the gist of my struck me is that it was you happy for you because I'm all right
but I mean that's just because I just think we used to go there to be a total union sixty three is the first you know
instantly going to the good.
So it must be more like I think it would have been easy for I've really got to the stage where it was really damaging
the Purple Onion. You know and the line because that's we had to combine to be you know way out of it.
What was the sensible who did this because I mean eventually somebody says love you.
Well what happened was I brought my customer who number five in
and I think we dropped two of my custom kit three do nice custom we came out of that
and from then on the onion was just there because it was established and the people who'd done on all the time too.
It was sufficient to at least make bread and butter
and all of the people who had been coming to me just filmed it went through that period after that
when the straight started to come.
And cold's Follett's that was before the Queen's And you know there were a few just sent in those days of course of
thought it was just people just talk about it and don't go out that is fun. It's that sort of thing.
So then domain I was in this for a year and we fell out of the money you give Domi the takings
and say you drop us into the bank and then the next week because you called a chick with bounce and I said to me.
What did you do that. Didn't you put that money in the bank.
It's of no board feds didn't you know this guy I know just with I had three figures on the top of my head of ten.
OK I was only noticing trying to get a B.S.
Together
and he didn't have a lanyard was that sort of because you only had the money at the dual no other you know two box at
the door you had two hundred people you could never make more than one hundred dollars all.
And if you had a bad night on this day and a bad night on Friday and the beat.
Sunday
and the just sort of you know if it was never that big money that you could make from a restaurant where if you sell
drinks if you sell food.
It was just at that all there and that's why you squeezed said many people in because that's the only money.
Now the girls are a really cool rage way just in my doing.
I suppose because you were king Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
and I maintained just the same as I was with King Jr many of those girls who said
and some of the wages of the supplement knew I was a bit hot in those days
and then says I was hot in the sense that I if it was they business if they grew their hair long
and wanted to be ladies and couldn't get a job there. If that's not at all. They said then that.
And for a donkey and I still eat quite badly. I suppose beings.
I stayed in and I were in the fifth onion gave up my day job and ran for Harry in the six
and I was the boss cocky going to actually close down before the end I was getting very very tired because I'd been
doing it for five years and I was always the style sort of and I always did you know put just together
and the costumes and in nice days of course it was if you didn't get in the shade by six weeks that's very yes yes yes.
And if it went for six weeks you know they told us they didn't come on it's so it was really that frantic rush I had no
life not much at all then. But because I gave a party to get you some of these records.
You know if you have enough of this he however I got very tired and then I had the other how do you come to do that
when you know that the two things that I really remember one was it all go yes.
Nixon was just staring them in the other which was the funny thing was the six steps from the ship
but rather it's what you get isn't always on the screen you're going yeah you're doing isn't the kind of patient number
of you know that your viewers in the other we all used to be on to that didn't we actually that was the sixth it came
from my regional beagle regional number at the end was the finger in the bottle which I used to send up because Jen
Sutherland you just heat and I used to do it to a forty five on seventy eight doing.
Romeo and Juliet the Jewett from Romeo and Juliet. The what if it was injured..
It was a thing stuck in the bucket not being able to get it out and that was my Mr B.
However the novice thing that's wonderful for me is Robert Hill
and the boy that is only now creates we're speaking about that number
and today me if ever they see a dreary show they were telling me that they said it's nice to think in the book that
need this with we should put the thing in the book if they remember it from Mr steer they tell me that the way to him
has stolen the finger in the book from me because he's doing pleasant laughter by you know how the America
and he's doing one whole scene chimping but it just got on his hand
but they said he's just doing it the Shia ness Innes it's not home but they were seen as the sort of sit down
and that was such a success is that the next thing that I did was the sixth hit going in for a lot of us having a
screen.
One was there tied to that and if you're into the tank to the guy things of the other two would open up the strip.
I was another we have a Kurdish if we have but it is devotees of yes see things.
Yes for the loves but yes for that we will attack he said that would have been sixty sixty four.
Then I don't know when I was getting very tired
and I said to go to Stuart who is the solicitor vising about a few things like they would YOU Mendus things I have
place. Hassles then luck I was the one who made the decision at the bill and in the boys would dance together.
The argument of being there before that was the last thing I were told not to the police coming in
and just looking around. But what then.
Dhoni was still there because I'm going to send him we're going to have to let the boys dents.
You know I said look we're going to be a gay club. We may as well. Five it now.
And fortunately just at that stage that dance where you get in touch and come out and you land up and you keep it
and you didn't.
And so you only needed one along and that's where the disco taught not touching
and said that's how you get away with it and
when they tell you need a couple of times they said who's dancing with you in a So I think that goes dancing with those
five boys if they're in it because then they just.
Min they used to harass is about the line
and it came back on me later with a local bloke used to come through to say I ten if we walk a lot on that we had in
the place and say you need more Lots of luck he would think they were the LOTS of the show and had dark hair
and they were wearing for me then I wanted to get out of it
and by then a queen had opened had become the publican at the Sussex hotel down in Sussex Terry.
No no no no it just transfer the mind all I did know just sort of this. And yes later on stuff when it's more of them.
It became like it was the first part of the breaks and to be end by I can play it really jumped
and I was very impressed.
Up until then I thought you had to be married to hold a license and he is that his and he said no
and then I went into it and realised you didn't have to marry and that sort of stuff we have known.
Was the one to do that sort of the brewery. Yes He just told us he'd been going to steward. So of this year.
Is he being equipped to steward.
So they didn't have any Wasn't I've been taken by countrymen that they finally caught him years and years
and years later I understand in the great Bond I become a public by then that I understood that they caught him selling
her the role. Whatever they did and said get and do and he left Sydney and took a puppet Queensland button.
Peter against him for some reason the place he wasn't open.
Obviously when he took it on he was your food Watkins if you want to steward with the mother
and he was not you wouldn't even think he was going in. You spoke to him.
So that's how we got and up until enough of us to do we have any. Oh yeah.
The group of the way that I wasn't I'm not to that I don't know what that he st was was a mean
when I first became aware that it was very much dark.
Which now it's me I said it's much nicer
and I'm not sure whether he was even there they knew judicially the docs wrong in the back
or I couldn't be going in there. You're from Boston.
There's a little room off the back of the jukebox that was much later much later years that it was a guy it not about
me being gay for months. You know I didn't know how it was packed. Again at last. So they could see day.
And maybe it was a nine day wonder as being can maybe it was in Sussex Street it was in city.
You couldn't park it it was quiet. It was easy in the sense of I know that I was told about it.
I went to it and I was at The Onion. So it would have meant that I had to have time to go.
Like I would have made time to go in there.
Like I wasn't
when I was working into the onion not a great team was in your head at seven that fit into the round until nine thirty
guys got in which we did. You know. And by then you just you get ready to go on.
I think when they don't live in cause the pubs closed.
Tainio you know to tend to because the pubs close to ten days she's chosen it wasn't on a Friday
or Saturday night I wasn't and never have been the sort of person who can go out for phones on the edge.
So I would have to make to do you know things which are things I don't know.
He tracked down down that I have to think and I don't let my friends of mine take company in view of the
and in that way down there. I can ask Kate if she moves into any of us the brave.
She's the one where we need to find out who I did not behave in check.
Because they've been a bit of a cop a breeze chasing of the sugar glossy they go to that thing is that what we like
but I just think it's socialist you're sitting here it's going to talk to you to do whatever he needs to they need from
the Sussex hotel to what's that street where around the heart attacks they are and this is a main street going down.
You wouldn't know the little battle just the one which runs down towards the route way.
It's a fairly wide street only with runs along parallel the hard part going down the road. It's the big mining story.
Yes it's a lever on St I stop a lot there set of lights there is that a listener strings of going right through Little
Rock you come out of the city so I blocked off for the Kings Cross on the King's Cross also mystery.
College truck because universities in it
and if you go over there at the university the museums you did call it straight down the other side that's worked with
Haven't you. Down got a way to put that in here that's what it is if you go down there.
There is a pub on the corner there and I told them.
That's not how it's McQuarrie McQuarrie Yeah that's the other I was getting along well the people came from the Sussex
today either Council yes yes that and it never really too hot.
I would see the trouble is there's another pub called The quarry in the city
and there was this big probably went to a Big Macor Republican.
Who used to go for it was in the quarry they got the hot liquor as I understand the gossip line suggest I said good
line and I wanted to be a public and kind of mention probably because it was you know this weird is another step up
and I wanted to be legitimate or something like that. So I want silly onion and but David Williams came out.
David Williams was about and book The Onion for me and I pulled my fist pump
and it was that which was the little girl that's you know. Tara wins the sixty seven thing I've made out of C.S.
For five months I was really despicably at both the pub
and realised I'd made it bottoms terrible terrible mistake because it was a tiny poem I didn't know anything about the
I thought people were on a system they were and in those days.
If you were the public and if you didn't know what you doing.
They just just swept the floor with you
and I did the pub out just gracefully just a moment of the I called it the vulgar room
and wanted to be what I thought was downtrodden Russian
and it was just the old guy just really disgustingly above it just never got anywhere near what I thought of this guy
today waiting fact the Queens really wanted somebody shake they were they thought because they'd seen you on the stage
the planning doing all those things that I was going to open this year
and of course I think it's terrible that that you know so I've.
I went away for a put a manager in
and went away for four months so I was in long way nine sixty seven days for four months and
when I came back I went back on the stage of the robots which was the only way I could get people in
and being back on the stage of the others of course they did come in that we could get them saved
and they saved forms for dreams and also had a back room for the river so small.
Yes turn community could you name the stage then what happened was that I was very fortunate because the son of the of
the X. Had the centennial That's right.
Packing up there and he was it was just dying on its ass
and he desperately wanted to get out that nobody would buy it because we sixes and nobody would buy the road.
It's the parking because it had that huge room.
Do you know that big of a minister
and nobody want to do it because perhaps you guys are very very bad because of this
and it was really good because I we were I had to transfer nine of but he took my part of the trapeze
and gave him money.
He's a gambler
and gave him money because he knew being the son of the publican that he could really run my tiny pub where he could be
I could be as much a tiny I need to make my money out of entertainment right.
And so he was just thrilled and I was still
and I would have been just off the show straight away if it is more all this.
Yes because I was doing the show has done it's rather jealous or interest rate out there
and I think unfortunately I might have had three thoughts in the first three weeks.
And the French just so you have a lot of soldiers that are going to be going as these you talk to soldiers
and just you know sometimes you wait if you did something and the queens did not come and so I posted the OK
and to bring home the graffiti that somebody had told me about the Fijian and Kate did a conduit
and she plastered this back with posters of films you know this here post is there's just no it was just a huge has to
say Gone With The Wind in the head one not the eye with people just wrote on there and just and it was a fantastic
but it really just there to introduce the graphic. What have you done.
You know scope mission which is this it's graphic about the police incident on one of the things which was an LP some
Isn't Paul Newman and I think the thing was a promise of gold what a movie it was and Charles had written out of it.
OK some of this out of Paul Newman's mouth.
I thought what if we were moans
and she said Oh you must be in the business you know she plays kinds of That's Disgusting. It's disgusting.
What you mean it's
and we know he means enough as a humane that she's such a sophisticated girl it's the ones that mean.
And I sit down and try and follow the self.
They just made me wouldn't let me go and said You have to take all that
and just we've been through in that we really do that over the parking structure
or you know we still we did that change the bicycle the path knew what happened was it was a terribly rough pub in that
they that place closed for we at some stage or another and then to get its new twelve o'clock license.
They had just a distraction that's when it was called the parking wrong but that had already.
I know it's finally worked. But it was going to go.
So it was something to fight
and I was some of the company's young it's other rather what's inspired A which is the evil station in the hood
but there's a lot of young you know just young like it always did have the bad seed had to overclock last
and say it's said that we didn't get the ten o'clock
and then being a day would come near it always I feel that I was possible that part of it was possibly the first part
of
and it brought him he said should hate me that recruited to use who woods this way voice from Paddington because they realized
that they could come up there and read a drag queen in the wind
and the next day they could get back to their girlfriends.
And in fact they girlfriend to come and say you can't I'm with Nathan now I'm gonna make it
and that's our own we use it
when you made that movie the six of us down the road Robinson that was actually a bit early then didn't have a sort of
I told you that so that somebody did show that because of the drug they gave us but I mean the bank. Yes.
I had night that Navy and I had done.
I said to me what we want some publicity things is anybody got any ideas about this
and you need to get this on the crop wise I have to American you know get some publicity for it.
Nobody had any ideas and I was leaving.
They said Does everybody belong to us you know I don't you don't you know I'm not going to be done because they're just
cunts and they you know when I was at the people I mean I wanted to belong to the union
and they didn't want to drag things now that I have a feeling it was stuff they can just stick it up their ass three
weeks later they published the guy kind of said that's really good you know and because what we've worked out is
when you finish the scene running Mona who is the new movie is going to come up and ask you to join Union
and you can say no and smack his face and walk off
and that'll be really good because you need to have the let's use them there just you don't get to get.
You said being that we didn't see that scene and the director said route we do it again
and they only know we don't run Lent and that that was a one time. Yes I think I say so.
We did it again at which stage of the month kind that said can you Debbie.
Don't you know a strange man and punched in the face his lines and punch up
and say well instead punched I think it did in the didn't they said to me.
Thank you that in the interviews until we tell you said they would read the part of T G B U two U.E.
They're doing things you know no interview next.
Comment no comment on the third day they said give an interview to somebody. T.J. Been in yes I can get.
Yes it's not like Chicago
and then in an interview you did all this thing he is Stephen I did study the story even if it's a friend of mine was
on the control panel at two G.B.
and They used to be on cassettes and he said because it would come down that mountain finance gotten on oil
and he said my kind not for bomb punch ups that happened was just for fun.
Tom Jones he said I think that's us going into it. It was the funniest thing.
Can you remember the other place that was very interesting to start with are these are he's used to be off with that
liberties.
By refine I mean benign obvious big hedge you know a rock up in Randwick bum down before Obama junction I know of on
the junction. He's been obvious.
I've East at Bondi Junction shy of the so shy obvious route stop at the time of the London.
I can remember going up to Shea avi's taking the band with me.
I used to have a live band and sing on if it was Dana Bash here at The Onion to.
Live band up with me got the avi's in order to attract the people from ideas to feed off of this day nine
and is the Queen's still going to Tories free as they are even today the Friday Saturday so you know you'll stay in
Germany is it on the same side as a show of his will was in an obvious bit cagey it was a bomb. It's gone now.
It's called something else now.
But it was always that was
when the original the old show it was great was that it two doors down from the oil stained buffet the birth there was
those are the heads of those for the book right now. Will I Be So yes I V So I V's. Shay avi.
Somebody and I do tend to put on direction. So I don't know that she's available there.
She can change will that she had just as one of zero zero two disasters was to begin with. Yes it was her first five.
Unfortunately started because she had a an electrician friend of Karen's T.V.
Why are you then testy clots for the show and of course the show went on I was out of season sixteen.
That's when it would be sixty eight because that was the first season on sixty and I produced
and starred in the first chest at the age so it would have been a nine sixty eight because
when she saw that she asked me what I was working I had the Lord Roberts and I put the show together.
I put two shows to get the full good and it peed in them and then I put another show together which I didn't.
If you would just start caring and I would have cities when that show up and.
And then Karyn did the next show like that show started when for about three months. Karyn did.
Nick show and they put in all the spent testing and of course the office to do a couple pictures
and jump to four o'clock and I said you can't you see the bathroom and then close down eventually.
They went back to both going oddities avi's shot he said.
So even when the bird bird cage was running yet there was still a wine bottle of it and the drags was still on
and the greatest
and it was your wife in the gave me if I don't I always use the start of the men will swear you started it.
Shay obvious and then went back into there.
In the main obvious big cage opened
and again that roughness close to his fucking larrikins from the criminal element goading from my pub at that time I
was struggling. I sixty eight sixty nine I would have gone into the packing in seventy nine hundred seventy.
I think it was only another year and a half then that the Lord Roberts maybe nine hundred seventy one
and the cage was opened. Then because when I came back it was still open and I produced another shirt.
When I came back from overseas and that's when I came back from overseas in sixty nine.
That is I produced a show for the and starred in it and then I was supposed to produce and star in the next one.
But by then the packing it come up and I went to the packing and I couldn't do the next show and.
From then on it struggled to be it because it struggled to beat because she struggled with Karren and it shows up
and down and then the criminal.
And came in and there was stabbing and I remember I went one night
and the criminals with their And I from the audience I really had a cold go at them
and somebody threw a champagne bucket which missed me and hit somebody. Next you know in the next table.
Whatever that was and are the arm into that not coming up to me said Oh can you please take
and downstairs they waiting for you and I just said I feel I can't believe this.
This is your stablish and you earned it. You manage it.
You run it and you are telling me not to go downstairs in your premises.
Because they waiting for me as if you aren't going to come down with me
and shit all over you know it was just they really did frighten his people
and that that's about time because that comes up against the services to don't know it's like seventy one of your
calves.
OK it's not that I'm going to have sixty nine did it so well as to being overseas
and sixty eight of us to come back in sixty I want to be notice he's really sixty I come back in late sixty eight been
down when caps opened. I was at the party because don't K.
Now don't I don't know enough and asked me would I be interested in going back to the people
and if she got I didn't against the onion she was doing some sort of deal with the council.
Yes I will then she can see the people and it's too hard to do but we've got this up a little Italian
and what it really is when it's called would you do the shows there. Yes I would change it three times.
That's it is different. You differently. And if I'm from right. Yes That's OK I'll do that.
I never heard from every can certainly caps was open and Rose was this done. You know that sixty.
Is it was the pictures that you did.
That's a long long while you were at the so that's sixty nine
and caps would have been the big picture still open then was it
or not it's not that open because the bit cagey Clay had another phone that's right.
Yes and that's when kept So yes that they really stepped in there
and I think an obvious went back to bombard all of that now. It was always there.
It would be would have been that I would have struggled back there here. Yeah that's right.
And in the meantime Beatrice the follow up also helped the Onion which was shaky then too
and to Beatrice is bittersweet. Yes she's And really when she opened it she took she bought for me five grand.
You can get all that after and she took and I sort of couldn't find anybody else.
Divide that section one the part wanted to get down there was that was that so that the business
or Oh no it was as should we have five or thousand of the five grand.
Also for her to run the thing that I would stuff for six months more and reduce the show and give us the two dollars
and I had somehow miraculously put in my contract that I could be found in the Regulus because I was then you're really
into him by the time the pump got true and I just couldn't see no way of getting She just.
This mean I didn't get a show together that I said to be I couldn't possibly star in the east and all star unit
and I stuck her in it and then went away to me if for weeks to recover
and she could bend you know you must come back if the show has been going on for four weeks we've got to get into his
in the next and what are you doing. You know page that money in you promised she could not do it.
She could not get into that that you could be tough
and it was pointless coming back that they just wasn't sure how in the meantime she had starred in the show that I had
produced in which is a very very good show
and of course it was still the only place that her that I knew was still the only place where she had a captured
audience.
So she had to for weeks because it was the other place to go they got on to that we could we just heard it was all
right so I I didn't come back for about six weeks I had six weeks off
when I came back she had produced show which was very very good for producing a show ever.
And she said that without it and starring I don't need Madame anymore.
And for me it was she who fired me and want to do grand bank will never forgive me for that.
MANJI years later months that she told me that she made the thirty thousand dollars in the fist hit five thousand
dollars that she paid for it. She made history. She stated she could never go to nothing.
You're just too easy and you know and she cut the girl's salary that buggery I thought it was pretty cool.
She went to one once pity and lost his way she could play the foreigner in.
Place when she came back they handed her thing that's a decision.
We don't think the wages are enough and in the eighty's he's dead and shit out of us right.
He was your spokeswoman Porgie been in the States from just a few get out
and the rest of them didn't go isn't mentioned Carol. Yes Jimmy Fishburn over the place circled Parents Council. Yes.
Did he do that. Yes he did and Karen Stout the parents started the show. Yes let's just Sunday nights All right.
I don't know if it's one of those huge on the corner the you know yeah the Turkish restraint mugger
or something like that.
I think what happened there was cameras starting if youn Yes And then of course I came back after being
and we were costarring so I was still there but she was getting a beachy
and then of being nightclub called the golden needle the dragon it was something opened up in Queensland
and a lot of drag queens we don't they.
For some cross number and it died in the US and when they came back there was no place for them
and said people like you got hold of it wasn't the spends money it was somebody else or somebody else's money
but he was just wrong there at the door running the show all over again. I always feel.
Do you pretend to set a target
and he never lift the phone during that knew there was a place that tried to open that some station that what's it's
good. I think it might actually have one know it you know and this is the skit this week behind the school.
The big basket and that criminal fellow he got jailed for setting up television so what if there was this.
And he's in Adelaide and there's always a few write ups but directly seen in Adelaide the week show and the big skit.
I think what we're about to watch
but it was a well Peter don't feed him you know the museum in museums he could mention from the council to anything
nothing
and he had wonderful ideas you can actually see the people that he got he was the first person he could use a muscle me
not something stripping I didn't go because I was it. That was the time I was it.
And because he was also the driver the sort of mile strip of place that Tory St Paul's was there to get on with you
know and I think briefly. You know you straight.
There are only three people sort of on but I do like
and I think at that stage I don't think the cross you I've seen anything in the CROSSFIRE guys did used to do that.
Well look he was very sweet was they were always in service thing I mean that was the jewel box.
It was the any so they never lasted long
and they had this knowledge of your future with Richard down the old road from Bill across my eyes.
What a road that never left that long are the people. Well I mean the cross was one of those funny places but it works.
You know it's the sort of life.
You're not same time we've got places without them
but then to the last that long because then Boron Leggo Well it wasn't a good night.
But it was the largest saying that they knew that like your male strippers thing they might have thought theoretically
that was it but they wasn't the only gay trade yesterday early. The only gay trade out there was it. The rich.
That's where you got a letter from shiver of writing that.
Yes because of what Norma's said as all that it was that was one of those challenges with our views will is that so
certain. The areas around do know that. What was it called champion of the child.
People just the Grace Brothers just about everybody stuff until this is another type the son of a slightly different
cut all those people started when you talk about sixty two.
What were you doing before then that the people you know about where were the very people.
So I got there but I got it simply because I started in drag.